yeah so uh I watched a movie the other
day that I think YouTube
I like the way you said that like it was
an impressive thing because you know I
watched a movie yesterday
um I think it'd be a movie you guys will
like uh it's called the Northman okay
okay
um I had never heard of it until Aki
told me about it because Aki's been on
this really weird binge of watching
Viking films I don't know why okay uh
maybe it's the fact that she loves
Assassin's Creed uh but like she but
yeah so she recommended me this film
that came out like not that long ago
like maybe a couple of months ago
um like didn't do any numbers at the box
office or anything but I was interested
to watch it because it's a Robert Eggers
film and he's the same guy who made the
lighthouse yeah yeah
um and I was like okay well I like this
actor and like the people and it was
like [__] star-studded like you know
cast like there was um uh Alex scars God
uh who's the guy who played uh Pennywise
and Bjork was in the film which I
thought was was interesting I was like
okay I didn't even know you could act
and like Willem Dafoe and like you know
all these like I like the lighthouse a
lot yeah yeah so I watched it and uh it
was the most [__] over-the-top Epic
film I've ever seen it was like if you
took the concept of a Viking Revenge
story and put it in a dark souls world
like the the fights were just so like
I've been meaning to watch it yeah like
you know how like you know how like
Eggers uh type of like directing is like
very like odd Housey yeah it's very hot
it's very you know it's very
non-conventional right
um which is probably why it flopped at
the box office but yeah apparently it
was a flop yeah unfortunately which is
like crazy because it was such a good
one but like the the fight what I liked
about this film was that like I guess
the guy who wrote the original
screenplay of it is like a poet so all
of the dialogue is kind of written in
this like poetry of sorts so it's not
it's so it's not so much like uh you
know I'm gonna go you know avenge my my
uncle who killed my father and you know
they will reap for their sins and the
gates of hell it was more like you know
it was like I will find the blade in the
moon of the night and like Shakespearean
yeah it was it was so like it was like
watching a stage play yeah but with
these Vikings and it and like the some
of the fight scenes were just like the
most 300 us like fight scenes where it's
just like so over the top so epic like
there's one point where they're like two
Vikings completely butt naked a fighting
on like the top of a volcano and the
volcano is like erupting in the
background they just like slicing each
other this is this is too insane this is
too epic that and and it made me realize
I was like why has no one heard of this
film why is like no one watched this
film because it's like it literally did
feel like like Dark Souls right like if
they made Dark Souls into a movie and
they put it on like Cinemas that you
watched it no no no it was uh it was
online I saw it online
yeah it came out last year actually oh
yeah yeah me neither so I watched it and
I was just like God damn like because I
still haven't seen the lighthouse right
um but I've seen like little bits on the
White House yeah and I was like okay if
this is the same guy made the lighthouse
I'm interested now yeah
um but yeah it was it just made me
realize I was like Vikings are [__]
cool
like I knew they were cool but like
watch finland's song yeah yeah but
that's what I was saying I was like
halfway through this film and I I looked
over at ARC I'm like you should probably
watch Vineland Saga because this this
the plot is basically Vinland Saga right
yeah Zaki no more no she's never seen it
I don't know and I'm like you're on the
Viking like thing like go go watch
villain side the households like we do
not watch anime
tap it
this has been zero days since anime was
washed
yeah so um I just wanted to recommend
that film because uh I've literally
heard no one talking about it yeah it's
so I watched a few new films on the
flyback from Thailand as well okay oh
yeah because I I I I was just so tired
uh I forgot to download yeah
[Music]
um I've got to download any uh anime or
anything like that so I'm like okay okay
God forbid I gotta now go through the
library or films on this live action
films live action films and for some
reason Thai Airways had like the entire
let's say Trilogy of Godzilla films oh
no like the new ones yeah the new ones
oh [__] and I was like
kind of anime right
just because it's Japanese
but you know so I just wanted to see uh
out of everything because I'd watched
most of the films that were on the
library so wait so it's Shin Godzilla no
no it's it's the uh it's Godzilla
Godzilla king of monsters and Godzilla
versus King Kong Oh no just like let's
let's
see what this let's see what this
Trilogy is all about honestly not that
bad I had a great time
um I didn't know because I I have not
paid attention to the Godzilla films I
did not know that they had made a
Cinematic Universe for the [__]
Monster films yeah did you know this
yeah I had no idea yeah I I just I
[__] love Godzilla I haven't watched
it but I knew that right because other
people talk about it yeah because like
especially like king of monsters was
like fan fiction for like or like
fanservice fully Godzilla fans because
it's like like you had like Ghidorah
come out and like my girl Mothra was
there I was like let's go yeah baby yeah
because I was like damn they're bringing
out all the [__] messes what's going
on
being just one film yeah just having
um and just you know having that one
film especially in like the western
films uh and there's that be it I didn't
realize that they had made a kind of
like a ongoing storyline with all of
these monsters and then adding like King
Kong into the mix and adding the King
Kong movies uh honestly out of I had a
much better time than I thought I would
had considering I'm not that big of a
fan of like Godzilla which one was your
favorite
probably king of monsters yeah right uh
like I don't know why that movie got so
much [__] because I'm like dude how
could you hate a bunches get [__] get
[__] on I heard king of monsters wasn't
as well received in like the Godzilla
fan base right or whatever or like just
the general movie going thing and I'm
like how could you hate a bunch of
monsters beating the [__] out of each
other yeah it made me I think it just
like lit a certain part of my brains
that I just like oh giant things are fun
yeah giant giant monsters that's cool it
was like Smash Bros with Kaiju it was
[__] honestly right because the whole
gang is here I don't think anything's
tickled that part of my brain since like
the the original Pacific Rim oh yeah
yeah because yeah I consider they always
are kind of like bash your head together
films yeah yeah
it was literally just ungo Bunga films
but in like entire cities yeah I gotta I
gotta say the MVPs uh whoever the
[__] construction workers are to
rebuild these cities every time a
monster battle happens because oh my God
in king of monsters every [__] City
gets destroyed my God is there a city
left on Earth that hasn't been decimated
by these monsters and yeah there's
another film off which Were King Kong
and Godzilla go at it I'm like just you
know conveniently or after like that
huge amount of Destruction and yeah I've
lost all the Architects survived
simulation it's got to be a simulated
wall it's kind of like how else are
these towns appearing back so quick I
don't know man maybe they pull like an
Aver and like a new you know Town comes
out from underground all right let's
replace it I go to my my favorite
Godzilla though is uh still Shin
Godzilla have you seen Godzilla I've
seen I've never seen a Godzilla film
you've never seen a real Godzilla film
just didn't look like my cup of tea did
you like Pacific Rim I didn't watch
Pacific Rim okay
[Music]
yeah
what no
be your cup of tea I think listen I know
I'm a simple brain individual at times
it doesn't mean it is the most I turn
your brain off I know it is
there is literally a giant monkey
[__] flying around wrecking entire
building yeah you know and destroying a
giant lizard the only kind of guide you
ask thing I've ever watched is the 2006
King Kong film whatever that remake was
oh the one with Jack Black in it I guess
they're Jack Black yeah that one sucked
yeah oh yeah everyone that came out
though everyone hyped that up today yeah
as a kid I remember yeah why is everyone
talking about it okay I don't know if I
would call it it's ironic but I don't
know if I would can call the original
King Kong Kaiju that's a never-ending
argument okay maybe maybe so many writer
threads I've seen being like is King
Kong I thought it was because they
always had like King Kong versus
Godzilla and [__] yeah
um I I feel like Clifford the bid rank
Donald Trump okay okay
like I don't think the original King
Kong films
yeah like their appeal to me is totally
different because when you know when I
watch a King Kong film it's like
something different right yeah yeah
actually really good analogy just seeing
it's it's more like seeing Sonic and
smash and it's like he's like the
American dude
it's like King Kong he just got roped in
like I I know I like if you ask me and
you put a gun on my head if I I just
said it you know it's like the closest
kind of thing yeah I know I think King
Kong became a Kaiju after he was kind of
roped into the Godzilla like franchise
yeah I don't know
yeah to me like Pacific Rim is still one
of my favorite turn your head off uh
sorry turn your brain off and just enjoy
visual cocaine because oh my God that
film gets you so hot I I always wondered
uh on planes I was like I wonder if the
the F like crew they like judge what
you're watching if they see what you're
watching they're like that's [__] dog
[__] because I was watching like a Spyro
of the dragon video and someone comes
over to me she's like do you want
champagne I'm like I will
Spyro watching Spyro the Dragon videos
I'm like they must think I am a weird
ass but I'm sitting in this business
seat makes all these serious businessmen
watching Spyro the [__] Dragon
reviews like they were thinking like who
is this guy why is he what is he
watching so I was also I was also
judging the person in front of me for
what they were watching right we got on
the six hour flight and I shoot you not
this person was watching minions and
Minions movies the whole yeah and I was
always that guy and I was like who is
this guy because I was wondering what
kind of person would watch minions yeah
business class I thought because because
we had a couple of like uh like kids in
the the business cabin that we were in
right so I remember yeah it was the guy
sitting right in front of me yeah I was
like every time I looked over I
just to check you know maybe it's like a
15 year old kid or whatever I look it's
like a 50 year old woman yeah
dead serious face just watching minions
and minions too and I'm like yeah hey
man
yeah champagne to go with mine yeah in
my head I'm like well maybe the flight
staff on judging but I certainly yeah
let me go back to my Spyro videos
thank you very much
why are you watching Spyro one ah there
was uh I had this video no I'm curious I
I like a YouTuber and he did a whole
thing reviewing them for like two hours
yeah I was like that's great it's a
great game it's a good video too yeah
yeah very good video I just it was just
kind of odd I thought it just kept
coming over I Spyro gameplay was showing
on the screen I thought they probably
think I'm a weirdo I just think I'm a
little odd it's whatever it's whatever a
little quirky
but now but look now we know what we
need to do I need to watch Lighthouse
you need to watch Pacific Rim uh well I
I think like if you don't like Pacific
Rim you just don't like IG films okay
well I'll uh watch it at some point I
don't know when we'll figure it out
specific room is the taste test okay
yeah figure it out then you can go watch
like the Godzilla films if you want
sounds good